the results of Christine Blasi Ford's
polygraph tests are with the Senate
Judiciary Committee this morning the
documents show Ford took the test on
August 7th and passed although there is
no independent verification of the
results they include Ford's written
statement detailing the alleged attack
by Cavanaugh at a high-school party in
the 1980s which Cavanaugh denies ed
O'Keefe spoke with the former FBI agent
who conducted the polygraph exam Edie
good morning again
good morning John that polygraph test
administrator Jerry Heron says the test
he used is considered the best in the
business and is used regularly by the
Pentagon and law enforcement agencies
nationwide the test began with him
asking for it to record a handwritten
statement describing her allegations
against Kavanagh he then interviewed
Ford about the statement to come up with
the relevant questions after that he
administered the polygraph test by
asking two questions is any part of your
statement false and did you make up any
part of your statement
Ford answered no to both according to
the results provided by her attorneys
she passed the test based on three
different scoring methods Hannifin
described 4jh demeanor during the test
she was very upfront was candid of all
the questions that I asked as part of
the polygraph he kind of assessed the
person and I felt her behavior I felt
her answers during the interview were
very appropriate so I again she was
nervous everybody it takes a pause she
told me she was nervous and that's
everybody takes a polygraph test is
nervous so I thought all the behaviors
all her answers I thought everything
that she did was appropriate what we
basically call us it was an unremarkable
polygraph test but is her inner truth
her what she believes to be true
potentially not the actual truth people
sometimes think okay if I actually
believe this event happened and I can
pass a polygraph that's absolutely true
that can happen however you that's one
of the reasons you do your interview
beforehand okay you ask questions you
ask follow-up questions okay is that a
possibility that something like that
could happen absolutely but in my
opinion and after her passing the test
in my
action with her I don't think she's
mistaken now the date of that test is
also significant because it shows that
this whole process began almost two
months ago that would dispute Republican
accusations that this was some
last-minute political hitch up we should
also point out that since these
allegations surface we don't know where
the judge Cavanaugh himself
has taken a polygraph test Gale alright
thank you very much